[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without we're gonna answer some
questions here in a moment I've been
told there's a microphone somewhere I
have no idea where it is but I'm sure
we'll figure that one time oh there he
is ladies and gentlemen podcast Shawn so
if you have questions now is the time to
start lining up we'll take like six
people I know for sure and once it gets
beyond that I can't promise anything but
before we dive into the questions I was
thinking Ryan last time we were in
Atlanta for a tour stop it was February
2014 where do we just started this crazy
hundred city tour and like I'd planned
the tour just right so that like we'd
have good weather throughout the entire
tour we start in the south and Florida
we were like started in the you know
we're in Miami and and st. Petersburg
and and we saw all the right places and
like we were gonna be in the South in
February it's gonna be okay and it was
like the craziest ice storm that any of
y'all have ever seen except Ryan in his
Toyota Corolla which we call our tour
bus with its Montana license plate if
you would have been here in February of
2014 and you're on the highway what you
would have seen are like tractor
trailers flipped over on the side of the
road people in huge SUV's going 11 miles
an hour up 75 and Ryan just plowing
through
all of the traffic with his bald tires
in a car with I think has three
cylinders in it
and now we're back oh yeah by the way
live from the Buckhead theater my name
is Joshua fields Milburn and I am Ryan
Nicodemus and we are live in Atlanta
[Applause]
oh wow that looks awesome you know
there's someone say take your top off
I'm pretty sure they did
hey we'll bury the lede okay you have to
wait for that minimalism we have a
special guest here nice we might as well
go ahead and talk about this so so Ryan
and I we don't always take ourselves too
seriously but tonight I think we're
going to because then we have a special
guest you you'll probably know him from
from the internet from his YouTube
channel or from anywhere else that you
you've seen his just really
inspirational videos would you say
they're inspirational that's a good way
to say well and I mean I guess you could
call him a spiritual teacher probably a
thought leader I call him an influencer
it's a word I like to use a lot that's a
very very good description I totally
agree those are all words they're all
words yes and I mean really if I were to
just describe him like if you were to
have a business card to probably say the
high priest of minimalism
ladies and gentlemen JP Sears
[Applause]
now you probably noticed I gave him the
fist bump I'm really upset tonight
because he said that because he's a real
minimalist he would have only one hug
the entire evening that and I don't like
white people hey I resemble that comment
no we were in DC a couple nights ago and
it's the first show I missed in seven
years I was laying in bed with an IV in
my arm you know less than 48 hours ago
and somehow I made it back here tonight
I think I was just so inspired by JP
that like I I I don't know if it was
telepathy what exactly did you do to get
me here tonight
well I mean you're welcome first do you
do vision boards Josh I sounds like I
should yeah so I just put a happy
picture of you on my vision board you
know work which brings me to my next
question
the next point by the way thank you guys
for being guests on your show I'm happy
to have you but you guys can consider
why are you here tonight why are y'all
listening to this podcast it's because I
put you guys on my vision board like how
else would you and your freewill have
gotten here if you guys ever want to see
something on your show you're welcome
just chime in anytime it's just an honor
to be a guest on this show honestly yeah
you can just call me Elvis Elvis yes all
right so we got some folks here with us
no question I figured here's what we're
gonna do tonight Ryan and I are going to
give our opinions and then JP if you
could help us out with whatever the
empirical truth is I'm I'm happy I'm
happy to humble myself enough to share
the truth with people who don't know the
truth happy to do that it's very kind of
you thank you howdy what's your name
were you from and then what's your
question hopefully in that order my name
is Donna and I am from Chattanooga
Tennessee
ah thank you for coming there and like a
good person because I can go on and on
I'm actually going to read my question
for you but first a very short backstory
to help understand my question do you
have a ghostwriter for your question
yeah sure
well actually my husband helped me on
the way here because it was like 17
pages kind of like your first book but I
skidded it down
no no no he knows it started out to be
like 700 pages but he had it down to
like 250 y'all have got to listen more
I thought you're you're making fun of
the fact that we're selling a book
that's 136 pages but okay okay so I
found you guys back in 2015 after
declaring bug hit me hard one night I
got so frustrated with a stuff in my
house that I just I packed up 26 bags
worth of clothes just clothes to send
off to good well afterwards feeling like
there might be something wrong with me
because I felt so good after I got rid
of that stuff I went online to research
to see if other people had gone through
this and that's when I found you guys
plus the minimalist community so I
listened to every podcast I've read two
of your books I think you have three I
don't know you know I stopped there I
think or two is enough and I've watched
minimalist I can I can very I can tell
you for sure that Ryan's read at least
two of our books and as I heard you guys
say that your podcast was out on Netflix
I had to watch it loved it
so and then so since you've provided a
great deal of value to me and to my
household by keeping me focused and
inspired because a lot of people say
well you know how do you keep going
I just keep listening to your podcast I
keep listening to the podcast you
recommend etc and I'm also a big
believer in that you get what you pay
for so when you started patreon it was a
no-brainer for me to go sign up but
every time you talk about patreon on
your podcast you say something that
drives me crazy do I pronounce something
wrong no you say you say none of the
money goes to me or Ryan you touch me
you tell us what it's for but so why do
you feel the need to emphasize what it's
not for if you believe and the value
that you provide why do you think we'd
care what you use the money for why do
you you it sounds like you have an
intrinsic need to say it's not coming to
dies don't worry about it's not coming
to us but if you provide us value why
shouldn't why should we care if the
money goes to you know it because if
it's a great question thank you
and and the reason that we said is
because the money that you pay to get in
here tonight part of that goes to me and
Ryan when you buy one of our books yeah
that's how I make a living I'm not
writer and all that money goes to me and
Ryan because we that that's what we do
for a living and so what we have done
with the podcast is we found an outlet
it's a free outlet to get out there and
share our message but what we're trying
to do is to build this podcast in film
studio and I want people to know where
the money is going and and so quite
often people will think that if they're
just donating and by the way there may
be a point it's something we're out
where I will tell you yes like we've
done this other thing and we've decided
to shift focus but I'm always going to
be open about where that's going and I
want some people to if they're if they
are feeling trepidatious about what
should I do with my money if you can't
afford to donate some money to this
podcast you know if you can't afford to
go buy a cup of coffee at Starbucks then
you you can't afford to donate any money
to this podcast and that's totally ok I
want this to be a free good for those
people as well but if you can I want you
to know where your money's going and you
can feel good about that and if some day
that that money is going straight to my
pocket that's okay too
like I'm not allergic to money you know
that but you will you'll still get the
opportunity to know where it's going
what we're doing with that that patreon
money yeah first of all thank you so
much for supporting us on patreon like
that means you have no idea how much
that means to us
[Applause]
the only thing I would add to that Josh
and I we try to be as transparent as
possible and and and that's really what
it comes down to is us trying to to be
transparent with our readers and I know
when I think about donating to a podcast
I really don't care what they do with
the money either but you know as the
minimalists I think when we're asking
for money we need to be very clear what
we're why we're asking for money so if
anything that's that's why it's it's the
transparency I love what you said though
cuz that you know it if you boil it down
like you're right we really shouldn't
care about what other people think about
what we're gonna do with that money if
they want to give us money great if they
don't great I do like that approach but
again we just want to be as transparent
as possible because we want to show our
audience who they like you know we tried
to live as a genuine life as possible
and we do that you know through sharing
things like that with our audience I I
feel like it'd be impossible for me to
have anything of value the same to that
question but can I have some of your
guys's money we had way to pay you to be
here right I'm kidding we can totally do
not any and another point about that
question that has nothing to do with
that question if you guys take just a
second I think Josh and Ryan facilitate
a very wonderful kind connection feeling
honestly like can you guys feel that
what I think I did you say for me to be
louder so ironically I think you need to
be louder asking me to be louder
but with that said I want you to really
taking over the podcast I want you guys
to just feel the connection that these
guys have facilitated I mean people from
all over the community have gathered
here to be connected I love that and I'd
love to contribute to making the
connection like warmer and kinder even
so I want to talk about politics like
seriously I
I don't think Lincoln should I went to
the theater that night
talk about hindsight does that answer
the question it answers mine howdy
what's your name and know where you from
I know you hate public speaking and I
was wondering if you had some practical
tips or you could tell me how you
prepare for each time you're gonna get
on stage for someone who hates as well
sure I can talk about how I got better
at public speaking it took a really
really long time for me I don't mean to
say that to discourage you but but just
to know the road that's in front of you
but it all happened incrementally right
and so I've gotten appreciably better
just this year right because we're doing
with like 50 tour stops this year I I
first the very first time I did any sort
of kind of public speaking was in the
corporate world I was 22 years old and I
had just been promoted after like four
or five years four years as the front
line salesperson to a store manager for
a retail store for two retail stores
actually as manage these two retail
stores in Ohio and I had this there were
small to small stores in the company
they each had five employees at them and
Ryan was actually one of those employees
and I had to bring the two stores
together and get in front of them and
explained that once promotions I mean
the dryest nonsense you could ever have
to explain no one wants to hear it but
they know they have to show up and
listen to me talk for a few minutes and
so I remember showing up to that with
just all my notes I had spent hours and
hours preparing and not only did not
everyone no one cared thirty percent of
the people didn't show up and I had
never been more nervous in my life
speaking in front of seven people was
truly terrifying to me and I can tell
you this I can tell you that once it was
over it was such a relief until about
five minutes later I realized like oh
[ __ ] I have to do this again next month
and the following month it was like two
percent less terrifying in the month
after that it was ten percent less
terrifying and it got to a point where I
started to actually get good at it and
inject some humor and found ways to make
it a little more fun even the sort of I
mean it was the most mundane nonsense
that anyone had to deal with but I found
a way to at least make that a little bit
more fun in fact I got so good at it the
the regional manager at the time asked
me to come to do that same thing for our
entire region and and all it took was me
just going out there and saying okay I'm
going to give us a shot I'm going to do
it and so it wasn't about I'm gonna wait
until I'm not nervous to go out there
and talk I wouldn't be out here tonight
because the truth is that you have to
get out there anyway you have to you're
gonna have to do it and you're gonna
have to screw up and some of the the big
screw-ups I mean there are some nice
after after these tour stops even this
year where Ryan and I are just like man
what a night like I can't believe like I
totally bond and then like we'll be out
there afterward in the hug line and so
on and bleh oh my god that was so great
I'm like it was and and it's because we
have really high standards so if I were
to give you any advice whatsoever it's
it's to have high standards for yourself
but then I'll also lower your
patience no it's not going to be perfect
you know you're going to fail and and
and bring those failures forward what
you learn from those failures will make
the next talk better and that will make
the next talk better and then that will
make the next talk better it depends I
depends what you mean by nervous do I
get nervous compared to what I was at
age 22 at that little promo pack meeting
no which is really weird because there
are 800 people here tonight but do I get
nervous compared to when I'm walking
into a coffee shop yeah this is this is
way more nerve-wracking there was one
time on on but it's not always nerves
either sometimes it's excitement right I
mean Ryan that there was a time there
was one night on this tour where right
before we went out there I'm like man
like I'm feeling nervous tonight like my
palms are sweaty and and I'm feeling
like this rapid heartbeat and like I'm
feeling this tension I'm I'm clenching
my teeth a little bit and you know and
in Ryan goes I know I'm feeling the same
thing like I've got the rapid heartbeat
and I'm clenching my teeth and my palms
are sweaty I'm so excited
what okay well I guess I guess it's all
how we interpret it so eventually in our
in the corporate world I got promoted to
Josh's job and I remember they asked me
to do this this readout but except for
the stores we did it as an entire region
so my my first attempt at this only I
ever told you the story because I was so
embarrassed about it my first attempt at
this was in front of like like a hundred
and twenty ish people and I prepared
like I spent you know some time on it
practice and then I got up there and it
was it was so nervous completely bombed
and it was horrible it was it was
stilted it wasn't very engaging it was
just plain boring and there was a
certain point like after the after the
the promo pack meeting I'm like man like
that really really went bad and I asked
one of my co-workers I was like how bad
was that dude
it was like well you know it was Stan
well you're no Josh Milburn and and I
really I really like took that to heart
and it made me want to be a better a
better public speaker and I'll tell you
there are two things that really helped
me the first is I learned in in speech
class 101 and that was for every minute
of a talk that you have to give you
practice for at least one hour Josh and
I put way more time into that to be
honest so practice practice practice to
talk because what happens is when see
what I did for that like the first
chance I had to like do this awesome
it was never awesome but but the one
chance that I had I practice but I
definitely didn't practice enough the
other thing too is I do start to get
those jitters and that will come through
on my voice and stuff so like I just do
like a little breathing exercise before
I go onstage and it's only like two or
three breaths but it's like this instant
way to at least like help me like calm
Lucia jitters actually the explaining
what the breath is so the way I even
learned this is I was walking back from
where I was in Missoula Montana I was
walking back from the office back home
and there was this homeless guy and he
was like you know hey can I have five
bucks and I was getting ready to go eat
and I'm like no dude but I'll totally
buy you some lunch you want to eat some
lunch with me he's like yeah that'd be
great
so we sat down and we were we were
talking and he's like you know what man
I really appreciate this alone she's
like I want to give you something back
I'm going to show you how to how to do a
I think it's tae ji like the Tai Chi
breath and basically what I do is I
breathe into my my lower lungs and I
focus right on my stomach and then when
I can't fill my air anymore
down there I'll bring it up to my chest
and if you do that two or three times
before you go on stage or if you're at
home and you're feeling anxiety just try
doing that two or three times I don't
even really think about the seconds I'm
breathing in or what I'm holding in it's
just filling my lower lungs then fill my
upper lungs and then release upper lungs
release lower lungs and it is a it's an
amazing tactic the other thing I'll say
too because I think JP is gonna have a
lot to say
about this is just the echo what Josh
said is you do have to be vulnerable
like you do got to go out there and be
willing to fail and learn from those
failures yeah I love that and another
thing what did I do
but something that Ryan forgot to tell
you in that story that only the did the
homeless man impart his breathing wisdom
on to Ryan he also imparted his fashion
style on to Ryan the guy looked good yes
obviously you know I love the question I
love your courage to ask the question I
personally don't believe that people get
afraid of public speaking I think what
we're really afraid of is missing
expectations both what we expect the
audience's expectations to be as well as
our own expectations and I think that's
the real fear and I think getting clear
on whatever the talk is getting clear on
the reality that the the purpose of the
talk isn't to worship expectations it's
to share your freakin gift with the
world the voice your creativity your
perspective so I think you have a voice
for a reason and I think worshipping
your voice is a much better form of
worship
no offense atheist then worshipping
expectations and then you know I've hid
the pleasure of doing public speaking
too since I was 22 and much like Josh
apparently his name
yeah like it's you're not human if it's
not scary in the beginning I think doing
that is how you get over the fear which
means you can't be afraid to feel the
fear you have to be willing to feel the
fear and take action in order to
eventually get on the other side of the
fear where then it's like registered as
oh this feels like excitement rather
than fear while not sliding down the
slope of trying to appease expectations
and I also find it interesting that
wasn't funny right
it was funny I also find it funny that
our expectations at least my experience
of them like we tend to imagine the
worst-case scenario that's far worse
than the reality like what we think
people's expectations are of us is
usually ten times scarier than what
their real expectations are and don't
get me wrong their real expectations are
crappy like that's their business not
ours
in my opinion all right hold on one sec
yeah we had two people clap for that was
minimalism before we move on if you're
listening to this at home and you have a
comment or tip for anyone who asks the
question today or is going to ask a
question you can give us a call for zero
six two one nine seven eight three nine
or send us a voice memo right from your
phone to podcast at the minimalists comm
it's my favorite part of the show we air
our listeners comments and tips at the
end of the episode and it just gives me
a bunch of stuff that I can steal and
repurpose on future episodes
which is really nice all right Ryan you
know what time it is it's time for our
hashtag ask the minimalist lightning
round where thanks for clapping for that
[Laughter]
where we usually answer questions from
social media but that'd be really weird
if Jay Peters got on this phone all of a
sudden so there's a microphone right
there
yeah well usually what we do is we give
you a hundred and forty character pithy
response we call the minimal Maxim's and
Jessica is around here somewhere
cataloging all of these she actually
live tweets from the events using the
hashtag les is now by the way where is
Jess you around here somewhere
she's over there ladies and gentlemen
jessica lynn williams she catalogues all
these pithy answers over at Middlemore
Maxim's calm but we don't have the
answers ready for you so we'll maunder
on a bit until we get something neat and
tidy that we can wrap it up something
pithy to share at the very end okay
what's your name yeah we got word just
changed my life I must say I just had a
breakthrough
you knowing one word of the Sanskrit
language so impressive a lot of people
consume because they're unhappy some
people declutter because I realized
stuff adds to the stress how do you
maintain your mental health now man so I
think I think for me a lot of it has to
do with with figuring out what is
appropriate for me and that changes a
lot okay actually I give you a very
contemporary example because tonight and
actually going forward is something I
have to change with this tour I mean so
it's important for me to a get outside
my comfort zone right like that there's
an old maxim life begins outside the
your comfort zone don't tweet that
that's not from me
and III do believe that I believe in
expanding what my comfort zone is this
is starting to sound really
inappropriate anyway I do believe that
if you know I'm just sitting at home and
and and you're on a couch for watching
TV pacifying myself kind of thing
that will feel good for a while anything
that is pleasurable is is good in small
doses right but too often we mistake
pleasure for happiness who that's
tweetable there's my that's my pithy
answer for you let me unpack it and and
I find that sometimes I'll go too far
though I will I'll go too far outside of
my comfort zone to a point where it may
make me uncomfortable mentally
emotionally physically like I am right
now and so one of the reasons that I'm
I'm ill right now could be the only
reason I'm ill is you hugged several
hundred people in Nashville a few nights
ago and I felt great but I mean they
were from Nashville anyone listening to
this from Nashville we love you
y'all are disgusting animals in
Nashville no I mean it's it's it's that
time of year though were there was a
whole bunch of sick people there people
just coughing it in the line and and
they come give you a hug and they sneeze
in your face and then all of a sudden
was they actually he went to the Huglin
he made out with every single person in
line I really warned him not to that's
too soon senator Nicodemus
[Applause]
no no that was too soon what's that go
on anyway
so I was in Nashville and I realized
after we're late
the first off the hug line all year I
love doing we started doing it because
we used to have two to six people show
up at our tour stops a really big crowd
for us was twenty and like hardly
manageable and but we still figure out a
way to give everyone hugs when there was
20 and we just carried this forward and
forward and forward and it's gotten to a
point now where it's like okay I don't
think I can do this anymore and it sucks
it sucks for me to say that because I
said part of the tour that I do enjoy
and I enjoy connecting with people but I
also realized at some point I have to
say no to that I obviously have to say
no tonight because all of you will have
a horrible fever tomorrow if I give you
a hug so Ryan I think might hang out
afterward yeah definitely man and and
dish out some hugs but so I realized
sometimes I'll push myself too far past
the comfort zone and then I have to pull
back and so always be be willing to
reconsider those decisions that you've
made that have helped you grow because
they may not continue to help you grow
in the future
that was somewhat pithy as well I forgot
this is things reminding me it's the
lightning round
I always forget yet all the third
question was about mental clutter did
you I don't even know if you answered
anything about mental clutter
well he's showing my secrets here my my
favorite pedagogical technique is if I
don't have a good answer to question I
just answer a different question no I
think it was so lame no I mean I really
do feel when we if we continue to expand
too far we're gonna go into this
downward mental spiral I could tell you
where I was two days ago
was not in a good place mentally I mean
just just literally laying there in a
hotel room but you're wishing like um
like reconsider
during everything in my life what the
hell the hell like I was delusional from
like a 102-degree fever yeah it's fun
we're at the airport and on our way to
Washington DC and Josh was there he's
talking he's like you know doing his leg
really like I'm Josh and I'm like really
engaged in this conversation having a
great time but he looked like [ __ ] and I
didn't want to tell him like dude shut
up I know you feel like [ __ ] right now
stop talking but no he I'm so glad
you're here tonight man I did Washington
DC by myself and it was not nearly as
awesome as how this is going but to
answer your question about mental
clutter um no I mean Josh really did hit
the nail on the head when you start
living outside of your values and
beliefs so for me when I think about my
most my time the times in my life in my
mind was the most cluttered it is when
my short-term actions did not align with
my long-term values and beliefs because
when I was living that life I was living
a disingenuous life and that is where I
felt the most mental clutter so the
first and foremost to deal with the
mental clutter is you be proactive with
it short term actions have to align with
the long term values and beliefs if not
then you're gonna start having some
mental clutter going on the same thing
with stuff when we have you know rooms
packed with newspapers and magazines and
I am just like kind of exaggerating
cause like I remember Josh would hold
onto every Lake GQ magazine Esquire
Esquire and because he did it I thought
I had to do it too and I'm like well
yeah maybe I'll references one day I've
never ever picked one of those up again
to reference it but but be proactive the
other thing too is you realize that not
a lot of people laugh at that is because
they have stacks of magazines in their
Faceman right I mean applaud if you if
you don't write minimalists you hear
everyone not applauding though so and of
course there are some tools right and
some of the tools I use are
meditation long walks quiet walks
listening to music I love love love love
getting into a float tank that is
awesome but but there are certainly
tools you know at your disposal that
that you can use to to help the mental
clutter but I think the best way to help
mental clutter is to be as proactive
with it as possible
yeah could we get a round of applause
for my beautiful red hair now I gotta
say JP that the hair is truly beautiful
I was especially like noticing this you
did a video recently the prancercising
video which and you were wearing what I
could describe only as a loincloth and
let's just say you're not a minimalist
completely thank you thank you it's true
it's true very actually my fiance's
shortest yoga shorts that show off my
lack of minimalism apparently and and
before I get to the important question
that I forgot Ryan I have to say like in
your answer you said the F for us word
twice and I didn't like it I'm I'm
[ __ ] offended that he swore I would
request you not to okay duly noted
so with mental clutter it's just a quick
two cents I mean I'm not the expert here
I'm not really the expert here
my philosophy is heavier beliefs but
don't believe your beliefs I think when
we unpack that for us that was very
pithy sure I think beliefs aren't the
challenge I think we're gonna have those
you're human but when you believe your
beliefs that's you being attached to it
I think that's analogous which isn't how
you say that word but I can't really say
it right
but I think that's analogous to if you
go around to your house and all your
stuff is in your house and you you
superglue all your stuff to the counter
to me that's analogous to believing your
beliefs but when you just have beliefs
in you're relatively unattached to them
then you're able to much more easily get
rid of the beliefs that aren't serving
you anymore the beliefs that aren't
bringing value and joy to your life and
I think there's a paradox of life that
says a belief that serves us will
eventually dis serve us will outgrow it
just like the pants you wore when you
were in third grade served you really
well when you were in third grade but
think about that belief have it served
you well in third grade and here you are
your 30 40 50 years old still wearing
the same pair of pants that you wore in
third grade it's a little ridiculous it
served you well but now it's not serving
you so I think when we can have the the
mindset and the heart set to let our
beliefs go and easier said than done but
let our beliefs go in this sense of yeah
I'll have my beliefs because I need them
they give me a sense of safety and
delusional certainty but I'll just not
believe my beliefs and in fact which
brings me I'm going to be 45 more
minutes here
lightning round yeah show of hands who
has not watched any of my videos [ __ ] is
wrong with you guys are you guys
deliberately trying to hurt me all right
we got a if you haven't watched my
videos hands back up keep them up
obvious the rest of you guys I'm gonna
need your help I'm gonna ask you to
repeat after me speaking directly to
these people with their hands in the air
you guys okay with this it's just off
the rails here so just repeat after me
keep your hands up tell them hello we
watch J P's videos we're better than you
so I bring up thank you by the way I
think we healed something there is a
community so I bring up my videos for
two reasons one I'm a narcissist and
likes to talk about myself and the other
is I do parody satirical videos on
things that I value so my videos are a
self-practice of me taking a belief like
in spirituality meditation clean eating
and then I use a video as an act of not
believing the belief which I'm not going
to get rid of the belief until like I
want to get rid of it but I'm the videos
as a way of distancing myself identity
from like who I actually am whoever that
is and the belief so I think the moral
of the story is like make my videos on
your mental clutter but the pithy answer
I don't even know what that word is but
I equate it to mean short I've just
picked up clues
have beliefs but don't believe your
beliefs
[Applause]
how did today wait hold on hold on oh no
I just want to say for anyone listening
to this since you brought up your videos
and I love talking about your videos too
there are two videos that are like my
absolute two favorite videos he's done
if you're listening at home or in the
crowd here he did a video on minimalism
so good and yeah and then another one is
if meat-eaters behaved like vegans you
what I've just done to you who haven't
seen JP JP Sears videos you're gonna go
look those up and you're gonna go down
the rabbit hole but you're gonna have a
good time doing it yeah you can find
them on YouTube it's just awakened with
JP he's the same on all the socials but
also different on all the socials howdy
what's your name hey Stephanie where you
from yeah Roswell's in the house tonight
you can put that mic down a little bit
you can say there you go yeah now you
can hear me because and do everything
and all the laundry so I've looked for
crazy good deals on everything how do
you kind of either reconcile that or
make it coincide with minimalism so I'm
just walking over here tonight and I saw
two retail stores that really stood out
to me one was a furniture store said
modern furniture minimalist prices
and it was leg stickered on there yeah
like this it was not like a banner this
is this was like their their claim to
you need to come into this store yeah
yeah they spent some money on this which
there's all kinds of irony in that and
believe me I know when you say anything
about minimalism there everything you do
is is instantly and involved by a
carapace of irony but but here's the
thing I have no idea what the hell that
means and I'm one of the minimalists
what the hell is a minimalist price and
then I walked by a mattress store on the
way over as well and it said 72 month
financing options available for a
[ __ ] mattress and so my pithy answer
to you is it's a hundred percent off if
you don't buy it
[Applause]
but how do you reconcile the fact that
you like shopping is is the question my
guess is there is some sort of not gasps
I'm certain it fulfills some sort of
need that you have right now probably a
need for certainty or satisfaction and
it goes back to what I was talking about
before is we mistake pleasure this the
short-term ephemeral pleasure for a long
term contentment right and so if you if
you could eat a piece of candy it's not
gonna kill you right but if your entire
diet consists of candy you're gonna get
sick and a meaningful way you you will
you'll feel it you're gonna get a
stomach ache you're gonna throw up and
you're gonna get diabetes eventually and
the problem with with the shop with
shopping is you don't have those same
sort of negative physical negative
effects there are other kinds of
negative effects we get we rack up all
this debt and I know because I had a
hundred thousand dollars worth of debt
we rack up this debt and we start to
feel physically ill from that and we
could go under we there's not a direct
correlation right and so we feel bad
about that and so then what do we do we
go try to shop more to not feel bad it's
like you're laying in the hospital
eating more candy wondering why it's not
making you better right there's nothing
inherently wrong with candy there's
nothing inherently wrong with shopping
if you if it's done the appropriate
amount in fact shop you one could argue
that shopping you know when it's
shopping for the necessary things even
during my talk I was talking about
consumption isn't the problem
look we all need some stuff right except
JP he's transcended stuff right I like
things more than stuff
well that was my pit the answer but he
knew I was gonna say it anyway I I feel
like I feel like what what's happening
is we don't we don't understand where
the pain that we're experiencing is
coming from when when that pain has to
do with consumption and and you see
you're gonna have to find a real way to
figure out where the pain is and that
could be the credit card debt or maybe
you're just independently wealthy and
and you have all the money you need you
can shop yourself into oblivion forever
and then and then maybe the pain has has
to do with not being able to have the
time that you need to focus on creating
or to focus on your relationships or to
focus on your community contributing to
other people where is that pain for you
once you figure that out and you're able
to link it with shopping it's not gonna
feel good anymore in fact I used to
manage a bunch of retail stores so I
spent a lot of time in malls I can
hardly walk into a mall now without
getting some sort of anxiety from from
just the the the stimuli all around me I
still like shopping I mean it's you know
when I have to you know go get I'm
trying the last thing I bought but I
really liked it I'm thinking like
non-food items Oh air pods I got the
Apple earpods so I was like I was
looking for a nice solution whatever I
won't tell you why I got him but the
point is is like when when I when I
didn't go into the Apple store and get
him I just like order them whoa we
didn't we don't have an Apple store in
Missoula Montana anyway but they got in
the mail and I was like God like this is
a nice little box I love how they like
they're in that little dental floss
container and it clicks I'm like it has
their own little spots I mean it's just
like it's a beautiful design I mean it's
it's it's a game changer when it comes
to like Bluetooth headphones so I guess
what I'm saying is out of as one of the
minimalists I still
still like getting new stuff the thing
is though is I don't let that drive
drive me into compulsion and and that is
really where Josh and I speak to there's
nothing wrong with consuming there's
nothing wrong with buying stuff the
problem is that when we compulsively
consume this is where it can start to be
problematic so it's okay that you like
to provide for your family because
that's where I probably think the joy is
coming from it's not oh man I got like a
million rolls of toilet paper 50% off
it's more like on why I got this toilet
paper and my family can wipe their butts
and I'm really glad that that they could
do that and you are providing in a sense
for your family that way so that's
probably where that joy is coming from
if you right now are a compulsive
shopper and it is ruining whether it's
your credit or whether it is taking up
too much space in your house or maybe
it's just taking too much space in your
mind then if you're feeling some kind of
thanks and that is a clear sign that
something has to change so it really
isn't up to me or Josh to tell you how
you should feel good about shopping only
you know honestly why you feel good
about shopping so if you can look in the
mirror and say no I we were on tight
budget it helps a lot for me to coupon
I've got a family to take care of and it
really makes me feel good when I go out
of my way to take care of my family then
then that's awesome but if you are doing
this and it isn't aligning with your
values and beliefs and you are feeling
that little bit of angst and yeah then
something certainly needs to change so I
guess that's my way of saying like yes
it's it can totally be a minimalist
thing or it can totally be a non
minimalist thing I don't know what the
answer is Jess you're gonna have to
tweet something out there thank you I
think the best way for me to give an
answer to your question is for me to
talk about me for a second
but I think it relates so when I was a
kid I got addicted to making people
laugh and it came from really low
self-worth and insecurity so I found if
I could make someone laugh then I feel
like I mattered to them because I just
made them laugh and I have value to them
and therefore I feel significant instead
of insignificant the insignificance the
low self-worth was still inside but I'd
get like a five or ten minute like
escapism from that and to the illusion
of significance by providing someone
with comedy and and I certainly don't
know your story but I'm just wondering
if shopping is your comedy if if
bringing home toilet paper to wipe butts
and I assume other things once in a
while but bringing home is swirl away
what else are you wiping butts what a
new sweater to write what grrrrrr but
but I could just imagine for some people
bringing home a new item that has value
on paper is a way of saying please value
me because I don't feel valuable as I am
and I think there's two types of people
in this world those of us who have
self-worth issues and then those of us
who are in denial of having self-worth
issues
it makes us human so I I would certainly
invite you to take a look into your
heart and potentially parts of you who
like don't feel good enough as you are
don't feel like you're enough for your
family as you are and yet get vulnerable
with those rather than avoiding those
parts of your heart through the
medication of shopping that gives you a
different perceptual experience of
yourself I am valuable at the expense of
getting further away from yourself
[Applause]
all right you a quick interruption if
you want to listen to our bonus episode
this week as well as all of our past
bonus episodes head on over to the
minimalists dot-com and click donate at
the top of our website
each week we publish the minimalists
private podcast exclusively for our
patreon supporters this private podcast
shows up in your normal podcast feed
like Apple podcasts overcast Google Play
or whatever podcast app you use and it
shows up right next to our normal weekly
podcast you know the one you're
listening to right now and being a
patreon supporter also gets you first
access to the best tickets to all of our
live events as well as access to our
monthly private livestream video which
is called ask the minimalists anything
it's worth noting that none of this
money goes to me or to Ryan instead
we're using your contributions to build
a new podcast in film studio in Los
Angeles so that we can create more
meaningful audio and video creations if
you already support this podcast thank
you I know that $2 often doesn't sound
like a lot of money I mean it's less
than a cup of coffee but it is your
support that keeps this podcast 100%
advertisement free because
advertisements suck and if we can just
get 2% of our audience to support this
show then we'll have enough funds to
produce some amazing new creations your
support is truly appreciated alright
y'all back to the regular show JP before
we wrap up any final words of wisdom
wisdom thank you
yeah yes yes be yourself that is so
cliche and so easy to say and one of the
reasons why life takes so long is
because it's so hard to do but I don't
really know the purpose of life but if I
was pretending to know I would guess it
has something to do with you being you
not you conforming to who you think
you're supposed to be to get approval or
disapproval if you're defiant but I
think the purpose of your life might
have something to do with you being you
and I think the fact that we're in a
room full of people probably also a
stage full of people where none of us
really know who we are that shouldn't be
an obstacle to us being who we are
knowing who we are in being who we are
are two very different things I think
who we are is way beyond the mental
comprehension of our minds so I would
dare say we bring the most value to our
lives and the people around us when we
can be unapologetically authentic in
ourselves to the best degree that we can
in any given moment so my my invitation
for you guys is always always always aim
in the direction of your authenticity
ladies and gentlemen JP Sears and thank
you guys for having me appreciate y'all
I keep going keep going so generous Wow
it's 45 minutes what was self-esteem
what do you do for an encore exactly
I'll do a cartwheel maybe thank you guys
so much for having me I know this is
your baby I take my babies so like
they're my babies so the fact that you
guys Josh and Ryan would invite me to be
a part of your art man I'm honored thank
you guys thank you so much for being
here man
thank you you can check them out online
we'll put a link to all his website and
social media on the socials but he's
just at awakened with JP wherever
wherever good social media is so and
before we wrap up though I want to thank
the Buckhead Theatre for having us here
tonight what a great place so if you
leave here tonight with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
see you next time yeah thank you so much
Atlanta you guys are awesome thank you
[Applause]
hi Josh and Ryan this is Cecelia from
Geneva Ohio
this is how I managed my pictures in
2010 I had all my favorite pictures
scanned by a company onto a single CD a
single disc versus an 8-foot section of
my storage closet occupied by photo
albums was a no-brainer I pitched the
paper pictures subsequently I
transferred the disc of pictures onto an
external hard drive that also contains
any videos that I wanted to keep one
three by five inch hard drive is barely
filled plenty of room for any other
media after I did this I then decided to
avoid keeping pictures at all for the
most part I had been using Facebook for
a year and decided to use Facebook as a
tool to me Facebook is my electronic
journal I can upload the picture or
pictures that represent an adventure or
memory that I want to journal and then I
delete the pictures off my phone this
allows me to store my pictures in the
cloud of Facebook for free and I don't
have to have a phone with a lot of
memory since I don't keep pictures on
the phone thereby lowering the cost I
pay for a phone this may not be a good
idea for someone who is addicted to
Facebook I am one of those people who
can take or leave Facebook I do not live
or die by whether someone likes or
comments on my posts Facebook is mainly
a tool for my memories hey Josh and Ryan
this is Helen from Old Town me I'm one
of those people that absolutely hates
putting something in the garbage that
still has life in it just because no one
has a need for it old torn up clothes
included this month I'm going to the
developing country on a Christian
medical mission trip what I've been
doing is I've been taking some old jeans
that I no longer use with really
tattered bottoms cutting them for pre
length and using the denim to make hacky
sacks I then hem the capris so they
don't look tattered I'm planning to
bring the hacky sacks down with me as a
group game that will be a gift for some
of the kiddos we help out and I can wear
the capris while I'm down there and then
leave them for someone who needs them
after I'm done using them this way
perfectly good jeans are not ending up
in a landfill I'm getting rid of excess
stuff someone gets a pair of capris and
a whole bunch of kids that don't have
money for or access to toys we'll get
some hacky sacks to play with it's a win
all around
hey there this is Anna from Minnesota
and I have a tip for anyone getting
married that doesn't need a bunch of
household gifts I'm currently planning
my own wedding and was kind of dreading
the registry process until I found out
about a website called honey fund this
website allows couples to register for
honeymoon expenses such as hotels
flights and all the fun stuff like wine
or beer tours or parasailing you can
customize it however you'd like and your
loved ones can pay for parts of your
honeymoon right on the site through a
PayPal account
it's a very easy process for both the
couple and the guests and it's taken a
lot of stress out of our own wedding
planning process
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
[Music]
every little thing that you gotta have
every little thing that you got you
gotta reach for and you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine without you
so tear your eyes
[Music]
you
[Music]